prepare yourself for a sleepless night
it is likely to be the hottest on record
according to the met office temperatures
may not drop below 24 degrees in london
and the south of england and further
north in places like manchester or
sheffield the overnight minimum could be
25 now 25 degrees normally defines a hot
day in the uk and it would smash the
current nighttime record of 23.9 degrees
set in august 1990 in brighton
these tropical nights when temperatures
stay above 20 degrees are becoming more
common although the met office isn't
sure yet there is a consistent trend
in the five years to 1975 the uk had six
tropical nights across an area of just
over 550 square miles that rose to 16
nights in the five years to 1995
affecting nearly 2 000 square miles and
in the first years of this century there
were 20 nights affecting an area across
eight and a half thousand square miles
now a lot of the focus in the heatwave
is understandably on the daytime high
but there's growing evidence that it's
overnight temperatures that are more
closely tied to deaths
during the day your heart is put under
strain as it pumps extra blood to the
skin to keep cool if you haven't drunk
enough water the blood can become sticky
increasing the risk of clots and with
temperatures high at night as well the
body never gets a chance to recover with
cumulative physiological stress on vital
organs the elderly are at highest risk
now a huge area of western europe is
enduring ferocious heat at the moment as
a result of a plume of air swept north
from africa more than 1 000 people in
spain and portugal have so far died and
while we talk about this as being
unprecedented now by the end of the
century the met office predicts that
temperatures will top 40 degrees in the
uk somewhere between every 3 to 15 years
depending on greenhouse gas emissions
climate change is making heat waves more
likely and more intense and scientists
say the quicker we reach net zero the
better